For a very short period of time, you were
the youngest person in the world.
Until 1997, there were more pigs than people
in Denmark.
Beetles often live within the fur of a sloth.
A single sloth was discovered with over 980
beetles living in its fur.
In 1993, San Francisco held a referendum over
whether a police officer called Bob Geary
was allowed to patrol while carrying a ventriloquist's
dummy called Brendan O'Smarty.
He was.
In 1923, jockey Frank Hayes won a race at
Belmont Park in New York despite being dead
— he suffered a heart attack mid-race, but
his body stayed in the saddle until his horse
crossed the line for a 20–1 outsider victory.
There is a village in Peru where people settle
the previous year's grudges by fist fighting.
Then, they all start the new year off on a
clean slate.
Kurt Cobain shot himself about one month after
Justin Bieber was born.
In Washington DC, the Slovakian and Slovenian
embassies meet once a month to exchange wrongly
addressed mail.
When the computer mouse was invented, it was
called the “X-Y Position Indicator for a
Display System.”
Until the 1800's, dentures were often made
from the teeth of dead soldiers.
Tasmania, Australia has the cleanest air in
the inhabited world.
When Coca-Cola announced the return of Coke's
original formula in 1985, ABC News interrupted
General Hospital to break the story.
No one knows who invented the fire hydrant,
because its patent was destroyed in a fire.
The northern leopard frog swallows its prey
using its eyes — it uses them to help push
food down its throat by retracting them into
its head.
The first CD pressed in the US was Bruce Springsteen’s
“Born in the USA.”